a 10 year old girl
is now being denied an abortion in ohio
and is going to have to travel across
state lines
in order to get an abortion because of a
pregnancy that resulted from a rape now
a few people emailed me last week saying
you know david you played this clip of
the speaker of the house of mississippi
saying i would be against an abortion
even for a 12 year old made pregnant by
her own father and some of you wrote to
me and said that was such a meaningless
clip david because it's a hypothetical
that's just that guy's opinion there is
no such situation and his opinion isn't
the law in mississippi anyway so it
doesn't matter well these are relevant
hypotheticals because they do happen and
here is a non-hypothetical a non-hype
this is a real story
the hill reports 10 year old girl denied
abortion in ohio
a 10 year old girl was denied an
abortion in ohio after the supreme court
ruled last week that it was overturning
roe v wade demonstrating the tangible
impacts that the high court's decision
is having on patients seeking access to
the medical procedure
a chi this is a horrible horrible story
a child abuse doctor in ohio contacted
dr caitlin bernard an obstetrician
gynecologist in indiana after receiving
a 10 year old patient six weeks and
three days pregnant
the patient is now heading west to
indiana given that an abortion ban in
ohio
which prohibits the medical procedure
when fetal cardiac activity begins
around six weeks had become effective
quickly after the high court issued its
decision
several groups filed a lawsuit seeking
to block the state law from taking
effect on wednesday an emergency stay of
the abortion ban was rejected by the
ohio supreme court friday meaning the
ban can be upheld as the case is
reviewed
ohio is among a number of states that
have rolled back abortion access since
the supreme court eliminated the
constitutional right to an abortion some
laws have been paused pending legal
challenges but indiana could soon find
itself passing its own abortion law
later this month given that a special
session has been scheduled for later in
july
so understand what is going on here
we have had
all sorts of different laws
around the country over the last
50 years quite frankly the roe v wade
era and in fact longer there are
leftover laws from before the roe v wade
era that were effectively
uh
what's the castrated i don't know the
right word they were sort of like
kneecapped for lack of a better term
because of roe v wade so they're
pre-existing laws that just weren't
really enforced because of roe v wade
you then had other laws passed during
the um
uh
roe v wade era
some of which were sort of like inactive
because of roe v wade others which were
actually struck down
um and then
you had some states that have what are
called trigger laws where they say
if roe v wade is suspended or overturned
then this law
goes into effect and some of them
happened immediately and in some places
they are being temporarily stopped
during the review of the law and in some
places they are in place so here is a
non-hypothetical and the reaction from
some is well we should be more concerned
with how the ten-year-old got pregnant
in the first place not about giving
people abortion on demand well but hold
on a second
she is pregnant right now
and in fact any delay
for her
reduces the number of places where she
can legally get an abortion right if you
can get if if the idea is well it's too
late in ohio but you can go to indiana
i don't know the law in indiana off the
top of my head but imagine that in
indiana you can go until nine weeks well
if you can delay her two and a half
weeks now she can't get the abortion in
indiana while we figure out how did she
get pregnant in the first place you need
to be concerned both
about how this happened
and how to deal with the aftermath and
forcing a pregnancy on a 10 year old is
not going to help her trauma now is this
what what republicans want is this the
country that republicans want well no
they would say we would prevent the rape
pregnancy to begin with that was one
from texas in texas when texas passed
its law
at this point it was a few months ago
maybe a year ago i'm not sure and greg
abbott was asked well what about be
people you know victims of rape who end
up pregnant or
children victims of rape what and he
said well we're this is texas we're
going to prevent rape
right well even a very well-functioning
uh criminal justice system
is not particularly good at preventing
crime criminal justice systems okay you
look at large-scale frauds of different
kinds and extortions sometimes you you
can prevent crime
but when it comes to street crime and
when it comes to rape and when it comes
to murder and a lot of these different
things law enforcement is not
particularly good at preventing crime we
can we can look at policy that would
reduce the amount of that crime but the
idea
that texas police are going to prevent
these scenarios from ever happening it's
absurd and of course it doesn't work and
doesn't happen
so uh i would say to them well how are
you going to do that here we have a
situation this is exactly what we've
been talking about last week it was a
hypothetical about a 12 year old place
to the mississippi speaker of the house
oh but david that's that's a
hypothetical
well here we've got a real one
and now this 10 year old has to leave
ohio is it better for i mean listen
ultimately she's going to get the
abortion it may already have happened we
it's been a few days you know over the
holiday weekend
is it better for her to have to go to
indiana
and leave ohio because of the law
doesn't seem like it doesn't seem like
it and by the way
there are republicans asked about this
who aren't even saying no no no it would
be totally different in our state let's
talk about that next
when i'm looking for a good documentary
i'll sometimes scroll around on your
average streaming services and they're
okay but i almost always end up on an
app called curiositystream our sponsor
curiosity stream is the king of
documentaries they have only
documentaries i recently watched insect
apocalypse it is horrifying what's going
on with the bees extremely disturbing
but the documentary insect apocalypse is
fascinating and i can't recommend it
more highly there's a curiosity stream
app for all of your devices curiosity
stream is always adding new titles they
have a ton of awesome original content
they have the big award-winning
documentaries by the filmmakers we all
know they also have smaller independent
documentaries that are often just as
good
on every topic under the sun and the
best part about curiosity stream is how
affordable it is you can get full access
for 14.99 a year not a month a year
that's a buck 25 a month when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description